مئات الجنود الإسرائيليين ينزحون
على جنين
غارة واسعة مدعومة بغارات جوية وجرافات
ودبابات على أطراف
المدينة
في أكبر توغل للضفة الغربية منذ عقدين منذ أيام
الانتفاضة الثانية نريد أن ينفصل
المخيم كونه ملاذا آمنا  القول عن الإرهابيين
أسهل من الفعل القوات الإسرائيلية التي
تواجه مقاومة شرسة، الجيش
يشق طريقه من خلال الغارات الجوية التي تستهدف الجيش، كما
قال
جنود البنية التحتية الإرهابية الذين يطلقون النار من المنازل المجاورة
بحثًا عن أسلحة، أنفاق متفجرة
في ما يقولون إنهم مسلحون،
وقد أدانت السلطات الفلسطينية
الغارة  وصفها بأنها جريمة حرب جديدة
ضد شعبنا الأعزل
[موسيقى]
في جانين، يقول بعض السكان إنهم
غمرتهم القوة الهائلة
للهجوم الإسرائيلي،
وتقول الحكومة الإسرائيلية إنها ليست في
حرب مع الفلسطينيين مثل زيتا
ولكن مع هؤلاء الرجال الذين يتحملون المسؤولية عن
العنف.  ضد الإسرائيليين، تقاتل قواتنا
الإرهابيين بعزم
وثبات لا ينضب بينما تفعل
كل شيء لتجنب
وقوع إصابات في صفوف المدنيين. الغارة الأخيرة على
مبنى جانين بعد أكثر من عام ونصف من
العمليات العسكرية المنتظمة في
أعقاب الموجة الأخيرة من
الهجمات الفلسطينية على الإسرائيليين،
لكن الدورة  العنف لا يؤدي إلا إلى
تكثيف حركة حماس المسلحة
التي تدعو أعضائها إلى ضرب إسرائيل
بكل الوسائل المتاحة، ولكن بالنسبة لأولئك الذين
وقعوا في مرمى النيران، تحذر إسرائيل من أن
العملية ستستمر طالما كان ذلك
ضروريا، حتى لو قالت إنها لا
تريد الحفاظ على الأرض، فنحن نركز  على
البنية التحتية داخل المخيم،
قد يستغرق الأمر ساعات أو أيامًا،
كنت أليكس في جانين بالأمس فقط
أتحدث إلى السكان، وبينما أصبحت هذه
الغارات العسكرية الإسرائيلية التي تستهدف
المسلحين أمرًا
محزنًا إلى حد ما حدثًا منتظمًا خلال
العام الماضي أو هكذا يقولون  لم نشهد
شيئًا مثل هذه العملية الحالية من قبل،
ومع حلول الليل، غادرت ما لا يقل عن 500 عائلة
مخيم اللاجئين، وهذا
وفقًا للهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني
على الأرجح خوفًا مما
ستحمله الساعات القليلة القادمة خاصة وأن
الجيش الإسرائيلي يقول إنه بينما يقول
المدنيون  ليست أهدافهم هذه
العملية سوف تستمر ربما
ليوم واحد أو ربما أكثر من ذلك أليكس
الخارجية